in other news representatives from
Sudan's warring sides are holding talks
in Saudi Arabia delegates from the Army
and the paramilitary rapid support
forces are meeting in Jeddah both sides
say they'll only discuss the
humanitarian truths and not an end to
the conflict hundreds of people have
been killed and tens of thousands have
fled since the fighting broke out last
month as those songs get underway
there's been more violence in Sudan's
capital as Victoria gettenby reports
a Sudanese army tank comes under attack
in hartum
another fires back at positions held by
the paramilitary rapid support forces as
representatives of the Rival sides
meeting Jennifer talks fighting is
continuing around the presidential
Palace
amid the conflict looting in North
hartum this meat factory was set on fire
I don't know the source of the fire
another fire also broke out days later
in a furniture store near us people Loot
and burn that's what they do they also
burned another place not far from here
this Factory close by belongs to one of
the largest food packaging companies in
Sudan
uh we received materials 10 days ago the
looters came and asked us about the
contents of the cartons then they slit
the cartons open with knives and looted
what was inside this has happened
several times
more people are fleeing the capital in
Port Sudan on the Eastern Red Sea Coast
authorities are struggling to cope
we hope the United Nations Envoy who's
now in Port Sudan will sort out the
problem of the syrians and the yemenis
in particular this solution could be to
evacuate them to their countries or to
another country or to put them in
refugee camps outside the state so as
not to face problems and security
challenges because of their large
numbers
red crescent is treating the sick and
injured
recently cases of malaria have appeared
most of the existing medications are
antibiotics pain relievers as well as
diabetes and blood pressure medications
we have comprehensive medications but
they are not sufficient
these people are waiting to leave the
country but millions of others are
trapped by the fighting and struggling
to get medicine food or water Victoria
gate and B Al Jazeera get an update now
on the ground with Heber Morgan our
correspondent in Khartoum Hebert what's
the latest is the fighting as intense as
it's been in the past few days
uh yes indeed and just a short while ago
a little bit after 5 PM local time
around 15 GMT we were able to hear Heavy
Artillery strikes being launched by the
rapid support forces against Sudanese
Army fighter jets and this was around
the vicinity of the presidential Palace
which the Sudanese Army has been trying
to regain control of from the rapid
support forces from the early days of
the conflict but it looks like it's
intensified that attempt over the past
few days more airstrikes more intense
airstrikes were launched over the past
few days against rsf positions around
the vicinity of the presidential Palace
airstrocks were also launched in East
Nile that's in the Northeast part of the
capital Khartoum and we spoke to
Residents in the city of umdurman who
say that they had to hide under their
bed because of the sounds of artillery
and airstrikes by the rsf and the
Sudanese Army so fighting still very
much continues in many parts of the
capital despite the fact that it's
supposed to be a period of a ceasefire
agreed upon by both sides the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army for
people to be able to leave their homes
and access basic necessities but many of
those who we spoke to say that that has
not been possible because of the
continued airstrikes because of the
continued artillery strikes and because
of the presence of Fighters on the
streets and being feared that they'll be
caught in the crossfire if the other
side targets those Fighters is there any
hope Heber that the talks that are
ongoing in Saudi Arabia could could help
end the fighting
while the Sudanese Army has made it
clear that these are not peace talks
it's not meant to end the conflict it's
only meant to open humanitarian
corridors for those who are in need of
assistance to be able to get them and
those who want to leave the capital but
have been unable to do so since the
start of the fighting to be able to do
that as well so many people here say
that they don't have any hopes that this
would mean an end to the conflict but
they're also saying that they don't
believe any agreement between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army to
open humanitarian corridors would
actually hold and when we asked them why
they said they've seen the previous
ceasefires and how it's manifested
they've seen the rapid support forces
fighters on the streets they've heard
the artillery strike so many of them say
that these talks even if the two sides
do agree to a ceasefire and to open a
humanitarian corridors if they don't see
that being actually manifested and
implemented on the ground they have
little faith that this fighting would
would stop even if for a little while
hey but thank you for that update Heber
Morgan reporting their life from cartoon
while they